hey there welcome to the season freakin
finale of a Westeros weekly this is a
show where we specifically answer a
bunch of your questions that you asked
us on Twitter and we'll get right to the
main big question in just a second but
first my name is Phillip Malina with me
as always my name is Maude Garrett
it was so clear what this episode's big
question was because it was asked I
don't know a thousand times and it was
everyone screaming at their TVs when
we're watching this episode Tyrion
what's up your ass right yeah didn't he
look a little bit upset when John and
Danny we're bound chicken went well
why you gotta hate Tyrion Karla getting
some first though we have to address
what the actors have actually come
forward and said about this particular
moment now Peter Dinklage explains that
his expression is just a look of concern
look kind of Angry jealous but no no
it's concern he says it's dangerous for
everybody involved sex okay John and I
know that [ __ ] lines up with what Kit
Harington said basically that it's like
a runaway train it's not a good thing
but you can't stop it no you kind of can
but anyway but either way what is the
concern over the boat boinking or
between Keane as I've said before TM if
you think about it it does make sense
from Tyrians perspective if that
particular perspective is about
political influence and the best thing
involved basically Tyrion does not like
love in political influence because he
thinks that it complicates things right
can you say tyrion and shea Cersei and
Jaime Rhaegar and Lyanna Robb Stark and
Talisa how about that one little finger
and Lysa couple dumb messes with
people's minds and makes them do dumb
things and yes I'm talking about in real
life too yeah I can say all those things
actually
if you do look back at Ian's
relationship with Danni though he's
always pushed other suitors away have
you noticed this yes a couple of seasons
ago who was like nah get rid of Jorah
he's got the greyscale by even in the
books they had like half a book of
travelling together and they were
looking out for one another and they had
a great camaraderie but he's a threat
when it comes to Dany so buh-bye he also
asked him ask Danny to break things off
with
Daario naharis as well we haven't seen
him I don't know all season so when
someone gets up in Danny's grille he
sends them away and I think that he a
maybe he has this boring explanation of
love is complicated and it messes up
with war and battle strategy but that's
like snore snore yes I mean it's
probably to be clear that's probably
what it is that's probably the accurate
one the actor said that but come on the
juicy reason why he's all salty about
this is because hello Tyrion is in love
with Daenerys that has to be it right
there it is that's the one I was waiting
for it is oh yeah
Tyrion saw oh yeah you like that so
let's have a look at some of the
evidence that does support this firstly
in this particular episode that we saw
the finale Circe says that Danny's
Tyrians type and to quote she says I
wouldn't be surprised as she's your kind
of woman a foreign [ __ ] who doesn't
know her place she's so breathy you
notice that she also does a thing with
her bottom and I get that her saying
that was a joke it was just to take a
stab at Tyrion and his past but I think
she knows Tyrion so well she's known him
her whole life all know his whole life
you know and I think that there is a
little bit of substance to that yeah and
it is it's obviously about Shae like is
what she's alluding to but even just
putting Danny in the same category as
Shae does kind of feel like that's on
purpose like remember he does love that
and she also incidentally gets to call
Danny a [ __ ] mm-hmm so that's like the
double insult that says he loves so much
yeah and then of course you've got Danny
who wanted to run off and rescue John
when things were going bad north of the
wall and she gets on a dragon and goes
off with two more dragons to save him
and he Tyrion is there going no no bad
ideas days days I say was it because he
thought that she could never come back
yes and was it because he's in love with
her yeah hahaha
the threat was really bad you know they
didn't think that she was you thought it
was like heart longing reasons why he
said don't go it's you know it's please
please don't leave me yeah he did look
pretty lonely to remember all of the
dragon
take off needs just standing there on
the cliff yeah any has had a moment with
dragons as well maybe he's in love with
the dragon I think it's just been a
while since its head loved right and
then thirdly Danny has been relying more
and more on John's advice or Eva Tyrians
I mean when you look at it nowhere as
Tyrion got Danny on his advice well lost
Highgarden lost a lot of the dawn army
and the Greyjoy's a half those ships
have gone as well so now he's you know
Danny's there going cheering what do you
think actually no no John what do you
think Tyrians like I'm the hand I'm the
one that's supposed to give you advice
so if you're not like if you're gonna
listen to him for advice and now you're
gonna put wink at it but doink my bad
but wink is another phrase that means
but doink
yeah then there is no need for Tyrion
anymore and I feel like he's needing a
purpose he needs a place because he's
completely ostracized himself from the
Lannisters yeah and as much as I do want
to kind of say that like what Tyrion
having this big crush on Daenerys how
sudden but is kind of like out of left
field it has been a long time since
Tyrion has been interested in anyone on
the show but it definitely was a big
part of the show and it's not like he's
suddenly like went and like got himself
unsullied or something like he still has
desires like any man does he's one of
the more promiscuous carry yeah yeah it
was boy yeah I'm talking to you so I get
them wanting to bring that back up but
also big thing to realize and I think I
remembered very recently a love triangle
between Jon and Tyrion and another woman
actually always was part of George RR
Martin's plan I have heard about this
but the third person in this triangle I
did not believe it so please please tell
everyone okay there's this very famous
letter that grimmy sent to his publisher
way back in like 93 it lays out why he
thinks that this game of Thrones book of
his is gonna be like a huge epic story
like invest in it go ahead like it's
gonna take me like eight months to write
it whatever but in it outlines where he
plans for the book to go and is a really
fascinating read actually look it up
90-93 george RR martin letter and it's
got it's like somebody wrote like
fanfiction about a game of thrones but
it's like really good because a lot of
alternate storylines that never came to
be but one of them is very relevant
because first off in that version it's
actually Arya who ends up falling in
love with John that's John and Arya
together because they grew up together
nice right kids this is not as bad yeah
it's still like incest II but also in
the way where it's like we feel like
we're siblings yeah
but there actually would be cousins
anyways needle hears needle I've given
you my no it's gross but here's here's
the weird thing to John if John loves
her back and that like he also is in
love with Arya they just hit it off that
way so in that same story
Tyrion ends up kind of being a bad guy
for like a while which it kind of
doesn't in the show too
initially but he is the one that sacks
Winterfell not the Bolton's and he has
to redeem himself after when he feels
bad so he just like he does in the show
he switches sides and then he meets and
falls in love with Arya boom John Tyrion
are you love triangle right it was part
of his plan so if the executive
producers you have gone to george RR
martin for a lot of content about what
to do for this particular season since
we don't have the books if they decided
to use that but then just switched out
the eyre part of it all and added in
Daenerys there is that love triangle
right and it could happen you think it's
gonna happen sure you know what if
you're in Westeros take a damn ticket
cuz everyone's in love with Daenerys
yeah like not a lot of silver head
ladies walking around with a dragon
creepy grey eyes - yeah so now of course
the worry about love interfering with
war still is probably the real answer
and then this script love for Dany thing
could also be an answer but we got one
more answer that Erik and I went into in
the breakdown that we shot
it's our theory time so check that out
it involves Cersei haha I think I don't
like it at all
that happened but who knows if you want
to get involved you have to watch it but
now let's get into our last check-in of
the map for the entire season until 2019
that's two years anyone by then this is
it's kind of weird like it's really
consolidating who's with who and where
they are so it's gonna get a lot easier
to point out but I'll just show you here
starting at King's Landing
we have Cersei but this time she's alone
she doesn't have Jaime with her because
Jamie is now you know somewhere north we
don't really know how far he is gone yet
and then this little tiny star thing is
because we know that bran and the Hound
were both at King's Landing they both
are probably headed back north they both
have allied themselves with various
forms of historic so and they're
friendly yeah you don't have respect for
one another
a little bit it's like hey you know when
you go to your high school reunion it's
like hey you kicked my ass well you know
what else happened the last episode
Tolman claimed Brynn oh yeah I'm
thinking hands like what is she look
like she wants to rip your guts out and
he's like yeah you know you know what
happens someone you've known your whole
life you don't think anything of it and
then your friend says that she or he is
hot and all something like oh yeah yeah
I never do yeah
actually they could be heavy material
too so moving over a little bit we got a
Greyjoy that still well I actually
called him a Greyjoy stark for him yeah
but he's still at Dragonstone and now he
has a new mission and that's to rescue
his sister who isn't that far away
actually because if you go just a little
bit over to the sea we have your on
Greyjoy who has Yara they're headed to
SOS to go pick up the golden company
because of that whole lie that
supposedly so they're right there so you
actually can catch up with them pretty
quickly then moving a little north I
mean we know about the boat and the boat
oinking my guess is that they're headed
to white Harbor which is just a general
northern direction it's a nice docking
place it's where John took off from in
the past yeah so that's kind of around
where I put them but we don't know
exactly where in the water they are but
that there is motion
ocean but there is also a full boat
that's something that I put together
when I was realizing like look how many
people are probably on this boat at the
same time that it's Rocking
we got various grey worm is probably on
it they were probably sending unless
he's on his own boat that's like a long
side miss Musante then Masson days
probably on it too I just like left her
out but doing King oh my god gray
remember my Sande oh my gosh is that a
badonk though it's a bump yeah shag we
got Jorah Lord friendzone
we have Davos who can sleep through
anything so I'm sure it's fine Tyrion
obviously we saw and then John and Danny
I think they happen to be on the same
boat and then up in Winterfell we do
finally they jumped at our Lee went from
old down to Winterfell pretty quickly
but it was useful yeah and then of
course in Winterfell we also have an
aria the little bear and bran
there too and then here is obviously the
big news I'll jump here real quick the
free folk berrak and the free folk plus
barrack are at the wall or were at the
wall at east watch and then what she's
petting is just a picture of Gendry
that's because we don't know where
Gendry is right now but the biggest
thing that's ever happened on the map of
the show is that look where the night
king is south of the wall this guy's
south of the wall one dragon to blow a
chunk out of it and I love how they're
just moseying on through there's no rush
they've waited so long anyway do you
know what else this map needs to do by
next season
nah all that snow all that I waiting it
all up huh it's going all the way down
Westeros now that's that's interesting I
was thinking about how the night king is
headed south but we actually don't know
exactly which direction and somebody
luckily asked a question about like
where is he probably headed and what
would happen when it gets to different
places I'm really excited to get to that
but that's our map for the last time
this season
yeah oh thank you but the real purpose
of the show that answers one question
where the hell is everybody
but the questions that you guys ask us
are you sending over Twitter it's our
Twitter Q&A section yes you guys hit us
up with those questions using that
hashtag Westeros weekly and these are
the ones that we see most often a
question number one that you guys have
asked but this one is from actor Jack
Hemsley four he says why does Rhaegar
name two of his sons Aegon yeah I'm
gonna tell you right now ah thank you
[Music]
you can get away with so much cuz he
reacts I have an accent too but it's
just I'd talk bad times what so why did
John why would John be named Aegon if
his father already had a son named it is
weird and you are totally right for
asking this question in the breakdown we
go into why this actually it's not the
weirdest thing there are there's
historical precedent actually for it but
sticking with a character reason here
that I want to explain that we don't get
into the breakdown you just have to
understand Rhaegar Targaryen was
obsessed with the prince who was
promised prophecy initially he thought
he was that prophesied print but later
on he came to believe well okay it's
probably not me but it's gonna be one of
my children that's gonna be the princess
promise that's why he even was like
really annoyed that he only had two kids
because there to be three heads to the
dragon whatever but he really strongly
felt that whoever the prince is gonna be
had to be named Aegon just as a
descendant of Aegon the conquerer but
specifically the first Targaryen King
didn't Aegon the conquerer he like
basically flew into Westeros on his
dragon and United all of the different
kingdoms under the one rule United six
of them yeah
yeah so it's definitely a very noble
name it's very popular name also in
their family too but he was just like
I'm trying to line everything up get
everything just perfect so he's got to
be named that so honestly when Rhaegar
annulled his an old yeah I'm like mean
old three or Anil his marriage to
Martell his two children this is this is
only were time earlier they might
technically now be bastard since they
kind of don't have a daddy he stepped
out so they would be unable to inherit
the throne sense they would be potential
depends it's it really depends some
people think it depends on where the
father's from some people think that's
where the birth is but the old Aegon
that he had with Elia Martell that
little baby wasn't a prince anymore when
he annulled bad marriage so that would
leave Rhaegar free to name his new son
and the actual heir to the throne Aegon
Targaryen right right also of course
regard son was like already dead by been
killed in yeah so I don't know I just
assume he told Liana like hey this kid's
got to be named Aegon I know it's like a
thing just pretend you know that hold
their family didn't happen and she does
kind of seem like she was like awesome I
don't want to think about them I got a
question for you do you think that this
is gonna be the same in the books do you
think that George R is going to call
John Snow a god or a different so I want
to be called Joe Harris that's what I'm
thinking cuz it yeah plus l equals J
yeah also Joe Harris is is another
famous Targaryen who if lines up a lot
better with John and and John's demeanor
John isn't a conqueror you know what I
mean Danny is so I wouldn't be surprised
if he ends up changing it in the in the
books especially because in the books
it's so complicated
there already is another Aegon Targaryen
yeah it's just hey you've got two years
to read the books if you haven't so
that'll tell you it's two years to write
the book all right we got another
question this one is from at Bob
underscore precious and he wants to know
it's gonna happen with Jaime's ride to
the north and his brawn coming with him
great question
all right so the last thing we see of
Jamie looking real sad and defeated is
him riding off on horseback away from
King's Landing now he stated that he's
joining the fight up within the north to
fulfill not even his promise but Circe's
yeah obvious put forward promise that
she's declared I thought that was really
weird in the show how she's like you go
you know if you do this as his treason
to the Queen do you realize that and
it's like you promised everyone that so
if you go back on your own word
you're literally treasonous elf a and be
like he has to look like he's going
through with your plan you can't say
that and then not do it right so we
haven't seen any Lannisters coming yeah
the first thing you'll notice about
Jaime's it is not wearing Lannister
armor at all so he's basically removing
himself from the kingdom from being the
general of Sosa's now army and he's just
sneaking off in the night right could be
why he covers up his hand right they
could be symbolic of that like the gold
of the hand is connected the Lannister
is like well I'm not really playing as a
Lannister anymore that and it's a big
giveaway that he's Jaime Lannister like
Hollow and they like gold wait a second
what are you doing not in King's Landing
that's a good point as well I wouldn't
be surprised that we've Bronn does join
him and I'll tell you a couple reasons
why bran did this great speech about
being really comfortable in King's
Landing he's finally in a really good
spot but you'll notice a he really was
happy to see Tyrion again yeah and he
basically was treasonous by arranging
the meeting so Cersei hates him
not only so she hates Bronn but Lena
Headey who plays Cersei apparently isn't
a fan of Bronn Jerome either apparently
they dated the actors the actors dated
in real life a little while ago and in
their contract it says that they can't
be in any scenes together I thought that
was ridiculous but apparently Game of
Thrones facts tweeted that one and I was
like holy Sh if it's from a Twitter
account with the word faction that aside
though I really do think that with
bronze training of Jaime like that was
his purpose that was the whole reason
why he was there it's Jamie's promise
that he was getting his castle so I
think he's gonna follow Jamie wherever
Jamie goes and at the end of the day and
this is what I want Cersei to realize
mercenaries just go to the highest
dollar they're not particularly loyal to
a person usually and I think that like
bran has never really had T to Cersei
he's been paying him so that's that's
one thing I also think that they're
gonna join and add up with this little
crew they're going to have Bryn Oh
Podrick and the Hound they're all going
up north as well and Jaime and Brienne
have had a history together hound and
Breanna now mates again they're all
fighting towards the common goal here
the hounds got visions in fire Jaime has
seen the threat that really does exist
I think these all combined they have the
same thing in common they all now don't
really like Cersei they're all gonna go
north and they're all going to fight the
actual threat the undead army that would
be a badass team-up I think they'd all
be in love with Brienne but then you've
got to get dawn because he needs a giant
ginger babies with her and then I think
there's gonna be the new triangle Eliza
hexagon her somebody's got their pod and
then I think that when they're actually
going to plan and what's happening in
the north you've got the night King and
beric Dondarrion every move you noticed
at the last episode was like that's our
new plan you kill the night king you end
everything so I think ad barracks
knowledge with Jaime's tactician skills
as a commander in an army with brands
vision because bran can see everything
yeah I'm saying it
bran is going to be useful next season
huh and they all together in the north
are going to take down the night king so
the real question is when Jaime does get
to Winterfell bran is there either Brown
gonna forgive Jaime because Jamie pushed
him out a window man baby yeah pushed
him out a freaking window the cat's paw
wouldn't have been sent to kill bran if
it wasn't for that happening though
right so this is active forgiveness I
think old bran would have been real
unhappy new brand he's
at the same time didn't he just bring
that a justice to Littlefinger you know
I mean like oh just everybody knows like
here's all your crimes you committed
yeah but nothing little finger dude ever
benefited the stocks really like little
finger sold Sansa and match amendment
Ramsay Bolton I think your wait it makes
sense that brand would weigh like oh
I've seen all the good things you've
done to you but at the same time he's
been acting like the three eyed snitch I
see everything you did this you did that
waiting waiting got an old Regan Sam is
the four eyed Raven like moving it on
with apps re on a thread can you do a
breakdown of distances in time that it
takes to get from white Harbor to
Winterfell and in the other way for the
night King to get to Winterfell so who's
gonna get there first with this distance
and how fast they're going okay you know
how much I love math question by the way
we do we go into the next night Kings
like upcoming motives and whatnot a bit
more in the breakdown but here I'm just
gonna focus on the concept of his path
that he's gonna take with his army so
we've got two options for the directions
he can go so first if he if you look by
the end that's eastwatch-by-the-sea if
he's headed toward potentially Castle
black so if he's going west you can see
on this map that there are plenty of
other stops along the way of places that
he could just totally trash and wipe out
but the most interesting point which is
a little south of the wall is right here
it's called moles town just a little
south of castle black and see that cool
so it's not much of a town but it does
have some notable qualities it's got a
brothel but basically there's there's no
boat yeah it's just regular boinking or
bed boinking bed boy king yeah but
that's also we saw it on the show
because that's where Sam got gilja job
as like a cleaning lady I'll not I guess
it could be worse
the other job we could get her to
brothels together clean Iman it's also
though where we saw last season
Sansa met with Littlefinger and secret
with BRE in there too yeah that's like
the beginnings of that whole storyline
so we actually have seen moles town
before so just like the officers of the
Nights Watch
maybe the night King is gonna stop over
by this area you know to build up some
brothel II
courage and then go and destroy Castle
black caught on so they're gonna get
overrun with Winterfell buy new brothel
whites oh and I thought there were worse
things you could catch from but it could
just be a zombie girl okay so we also
know that Winterfell to Castle black is
about 600 650 miles so if we use a
little pipe back there I'm there the
night then I Kings trip there could be
like a hundred and sixty miles in other
words not that far and the dead they
seem to stagger kind of at the rate of
like a normal human walking pace which
is about like one and a half miles so
that's about four and a half days of
non-stop walking for them to get from
east watch to moles town potentially
which is also right by Castle black and
they're not going to sleep that I need a
camp they don't need to young they can
keep going but wait are you ready for
more math I'm sorry you're so ready for
mat because who says the night King is
going west right like well it was an
option but actually I do have to
acknowledge that the wildlings mostly
destroyed moles town and we we don't
technically know if there's anyone even
there anymore so he doesn't need to go
that way and he also doesn't need to
destroy Castle black because he's
already on the south of the wall so
there are a few other really interesting
places if he does decide to go south
instead so again he's that Eastwatch was
an upper right corner there if he goes
south he'll hit a little place called
last hearth and southeast karhold now
last hearth is the seat of house number
and karhold is the seat of the Karstarks
so basically you remember little Ned
umber and Alice Karstark yeah the night
king is coming for them and I love that
so much last hearth is only like five
and a half days march from Eastwatch and
car hold is like maybe like six days
from there so of course obviously if
otherwise is all ignoring like the speed
of dragon flight and the fact that the
dead can just barely run whatever he
makes him do that as well Giants I could
just throw the whites go way faster but
finally either way like I think that's
interesting but the most obvious place
of where he's probably headed is
Winterfell he wants to get bran
let's be honest yeah I mean he's
attracted to bran and not in that way
but maybe in that way you know bran is
very vain that's a reference that bran
maybe being the night King but
Winterfell is is I think the most likely
place that's the one that we care about
yes that's where the real threat is but
how long is it gonna take to get there
okay I'm glad you asked cause more math
okay at marching speeds actually it
would take a little while like two and a
half weeks like all the other places
were a few days away but two and a half
weeks so unless you decide to do some of
that picking up the pace the Giants
throwing the weights or whatever and
considering that next season is only six
freaking episodes long I gotta say I
think Winterfell is going to be the
location of the big final showdown
between humanity and the night's king
king's army like that's it's got to be
there it would take them too long to get
anywhere else that's like my main reason
but also of course Winterfell it's the
seat of House Stark yeah what better
staged for the final battle against the
winter that has always been coming
according to them especially because
that place is known for a big fancy
crypt underneath oh yeah hello Ned there
he is
I don't think Ned but there's a lot of
dead bodies down there oh my gosh didn't
even think about that they're gonna
raise Ned
I recognize that torso I do remember
though when Jamie Lannister was planning
he said that Dothraki Army would take to
fortnight's to get to Winterfell
that is a month so the night's king and
his army is gonna get to Winterfell one
and a half weeks sooner except the show
does different stuff what do you mean I
just mean that they like they pick
whatever's whatever time is convenient
for them which a I appreciate a better
tension and better conflict you came in
with Pythagoras theorem I might I know
with knowing what a fortnight was okay
two of them a month we're both mildly
intelligent we both have eighth grade
knowledge no my point is just like of
course they're gonna manipulate the
timeline yeah I mean let's all remember
it took them seven years to get like the
same distance we're talking about yeah
yeah I love that fast-forward button
when it comes to travel though good
stuff yeah we do have another question
though this one comes in from a two pure
Muhannad who says when did ayah and
Sansa planned all that just this episode
did bran tell them in the godswood
earlier I happened at Westeros weekly
all right first of all I'm gonna say
there's not really any way for us to
know for sure I did watch the after
episode with the executive producers and
they wanted to keep the audience in the
dark about it and just reveal it at the
eleventh hour so there was a lot of
missing conversation in there which was
a little bit hard now the fact that ayah
and science has arguments seemed pretty
authentic and they weren't doing that in
front of anyone else kind of makes sense
that they weren't really on the same
page until recently so that right
dickering that they had and like that's
Reggie yeah like the way that the Arya
was snooping accosted and accused Sansa
she went into her bag found a freaking
face mask like there's a lot of reason
why they wouldn't be seeing eye to eye
at all right you would think they'd be
like are they watching is he looking if
it was exactly sorry I will throw out
though this theory that the moment the
Sansa sends Brennan away
remember how she's like you have to go
right now you know basically because
Littlefinger was saying that Brienne
could be used against Arya to take her
out
that's definitely evidence of some
amount of scheming against
Littlefinger's plans right at least as
far back is that we talked about that in
another episode where especially like it
definitely felt like she was aware of
what he was trying to do and it's like
well I'm smarter than that it's just
whether or not she started to scheme
against him at the time it's tough to
know it might have started the scheming
that he is right off to Peter implies
that I is a threat to Sansa all right
yeah it could be as recent as after
Littlefinger trying to get sounds like
to think of aya as someone who wants to
kill her that happen this time either
way I think a conversation with bran
probably happened when we never saw the
conversation did happen so I just got a
text from someone that sitting in this
room with knowledge that we don't have
because this just came out as we're
filming this the actor that plays brand
said that yeah they shot a scene in a
guy it got cut where Sansa goes to him
and says I need your help
it's like oh wait I'm an idiot I have a
security camera guy I'm telling you the
three eyed snitch you would feel so
bummed out if you're Isaac because he's
been copying a lot of hate this episode
well bran has he's character a lot of
heat for just knowing everything and
doing nothing and we didn't get that
payoff from him involving himself in a
way that helped and benefited this
fascinating because I I felt like it was
implied like he was sitting there at the
table with her so just felt like oh
they've consulted with them and when he
tried to deny it and is like you know
yeah you weren't there none of you were
there actually he's so emo now I wrote a
song about it anyway that's that's
pretty much does that question yes they
all schemed yes I talked about it but I
think it's symbolic because Littlefinger
always had one step ahead or even three
steps ahead in the game of Thrones I
even said to son so constantly play out
every scenario right I in worst case but
be everything happening at the same time
every scenario and yet he was completely
blind so I love that okay yeah I love
that like the note where like I'm sure
in the script it's like Littlefinger is
dumbfounded for
first time yeah he didn't see it coming
at all death though I know that is an
assassin sigh doesn't need to grow to us
crew to Utley kill anyone just a couple
of steps before she's asleep
I don't know of like you know she
visited the body played such a prominent
role for seven seasons like oh did ya do
a shot you know what screw Jays also I
just remembered like varus outlived them
like you kind of just like always pair
those two together is like yeah you know
who you that said like little fingers
always been playing for himself and if
you take various at his word he's
playing for the realm so maybe that
noble cause and Littlefinger had a
little thing called left for redheads
right formant yeah speaking of yeah what
is it well it's from at Jack Hemsley
full again again Bloods he was noise
Tolman dead he's our favorite redhead
man dead oh man okay so our last
question before predictions and power
rankings by the way I season eight
predictions by the way but yeah I know
it definitely looks like a really
inescapable situation for torment and
for beric Dondarrion so to answer it
like just straight up did they die we
just what Ike watched it to get real
clear here about the key moment and I'm
just gonna give my best guess we know
barek and torment we're standing there
at the top of the wall as you can see
and then we see them turn back and they
see the walls collapsing behind them you
can see that you know when a performance
guys about to go plummeting down so this
right here is the last shot that we have
for sure of what's going on with torment
so I can't say for sure but if this
section of the wall that he's currently
standing on did not come tumbling down
like it did for his friend which looks
like it's possible if you look at this
shot over here you can see that section
of the wall there zoom in on that
it's just a chunk out of the wall the
entire wall well and it's everything
kind of to the left or I guess to the
east
yeah decided like headed toward the
ocean fell into the ocean but that one
cliff right there that feels like right
torment and beric could be standing so I
guess they could have just narrowly
escaped and that would make sense
because these characters definitely
deserve a clear on-screen death if that
ever happens for them now
here's my real question about the
situation what about Gendry my baby boy
yeah because last we heard he was
recovering from that marathon run at
East walk brave burst O'Brien yeah to
run away from a fight so one that's what
they tell a kid who can't fight it's
like well you're you that's why God made
you fast and yeah I'm just like a little
bit like all Gendry is gonna be such a
badass
and then he didn't get to be one the
season I'd be telling me I'm hoping he
will be nice unless he's dead yeah okay
I don't think they would kill him either
without showing it so I guess we just
have to hope that he's like also Undine
his boat and we just sure he was he was
under the bed the whole time they were
missing - he also is disapproving of it
him and Tyrion are gonna have all
[ __ ] not a body not with Davos
they're chummy and Davos behind the
curtain it's a small boat Oh a lot of
people quiet anyway let's move on to
power ranking mm this is of course where
you vote who you think had the most
influence and who's the strongest
character and who's basically on their
way to the Game of Thrones aka now
ultimate destruction yeah so anyway yeah
you've got the votes in it's a finale
who's got the power of the last episode
of the season tell me
both finale coming in at number three
with eight percent finally first I'm on
the board son sister
welcome to the board Sansa successful
Lady of Winterfell now she doesn't just
not getting challenged
she's soon gonna find out or if not
doesn't already know that John isn't a
stark so she holds full power of
Winterfell now which will be the threat
of the upcoming season yes good point
so she's the Lord well the lady of the
house that is again yeah part of the
central conflict that's gonna happen but
also in the same way that Ned would
been in the end by that I mean like
she's really filling her father's shoes
yeah we see that this episode when she's
the judge and she's she's kind of being
just at the same time you know as the
executioner right yeah so if she
definitely has stepped into a role where
I do totally get she kind of almost is
queen of the north yeah and because
Winterfell is gonna be so important I
get her being on the board for sure I
earned it this episode I think he
realized that we've not her working
against ire but with aya those two
together are going to be quite a
formidable force I feel like there are
yin and yang like their opposite thing
yet they're a whole when they're
together kind of like iron I was in drag
on oh yeah and he pulls the shots but
drug on executed yeah kind of very very
similar to though that's interesting
who's next Jon Snow Oh a bit of a climb
21.4% of you guys voted for John he's
he's got power alright and I always
wanted
stop talking what I was haha I always
want a ghost to ride dragged on but
instead a wolf rode a dragon well he's
kind of like it goes cuz he did die yeah
and but there his heart is uh funny
still pumping something else is to would
stir one number one is nice oh the jelly
man himself 40.2% it's my favorite gift
guys if you haven't tweeted it yet you
missing yet because he does a little
dance I love the people I don't know
what you're referencing oh oh the night
key waiter that's tripping without his
at all not talking but the waiter the
night waiter the night King killed over
then hi King is I'm amazing like
throughout see what I mean like if you
if you really think about it this guy is
just owning Westeros look how badass he
looks here like he looks cooler than
Danny does Danny holds drogon like
really low and go
I might flip yeah that seems like let's
do this I feel like this is a man who
has waited so long for the perfect piece
to put into his puzzle like this is a
man of patience who's waiting like who's
happily going to let a lot of little
things happen over the course of
centuries and that doesn't even matter
until the one big thing happens and
that's the wall and now it's down what's
the dragon then the wall yeah and if you
watch our last episode you know that if
he's planning all of this and can see
all of it kind of the way bran can see a
lot of these things yeah maybe he's been
that patient that long and just doing
chess moves at a macro level that are
like across a thousand years yeah and by
the way it's like a no-brainer that you
know killcount why's that well there was
one person add the one cat's paw opened
at little fingers right but the person
actually wins the kill count right fine
it's the night king night kings taking
out everything that king wins again man
this picture looks like upside down it's
how many did he kill this is the thing
he blasted a chunk in a wall when we saw
it torment up there with beric it seemed
it's just not no one there could be
anywhere from 2 to 100 right so let's
say a verge that sure 52 10 52 person
kill count there so that's pretty huge
actually in the grand scheme of the
season but speaking of the grand scheme
of the season and since it's the end of
the season we actually did a whole other
Power Rankings and kill count for the
entirety of the season yeah all seven
episodes we have combined all the kills
and then all the percentages that you
guys voted in the polls altogether so
let's kick it off with the kill count
for the entire season whole see the
winners oh yeah coming in at number
three mmm someone narrowly beat out Jon
Snow is darkman I had stock got about 36
kills
man just from opening the season up by
opening up a lot of people yeah yeah she
that number like stayed legit I hope she
wasn't all into this burning the body
thing don't you got to Winterfell mmm
even now
great so she comes in third place for
the entirety of the season of other kill
counts just barely though uh coming in
number two night king anyone who killed
at the wall we're saying fifty two so he
killed 52 people so every all of the
free folk basically that were the new
Knights watch kills him but then he
brings him back so did they really die
yes coming in at number one take a stab
it is the tag-team champions of the
world Danny and dragged on man
we're looking at about three hundred and
thirty four kills season every other
side I feel like she just took someone
out oh joy
she's like Genghis Khan or something
like this is amazing like I don't think
I don't know that we'll ever see anyone
hit a number like that like Danny this
season might have just maxed it out and
ruined it for like the integrity of the
show all the next season technically
that's my blood on her hands well if you
make it drug on we did decide in right
killcount how it works it's like if
you're using it like a tool yeah then it
goes to her but yeah I mean yeah I do
want to see Danny grab one person like
just choke them real bad what about the
power for the entire season so if you
were like me and started voting as well
uh-huh everybody count towards this
coming in at number three it was a
three-way tie between Jon Snow Cersei
Lannister and euron greyjoy
all three of them had pretty much an
equal percentage in third place yeah and
by the way the math on this is like
based on all of your votes kind of who
were consistently showing up at the top
and then kind of what they're voting
average was its its scientific link but
these three definitely represent them
very often we're in the tops of the
Power Rankings what's fascinating about
this is that Euron's even there at all
and again I'm gonna say it's because
he's that force of chaos we're like you
know she's got this huge plan he's got
this huge plan and him just playing for
himself a table messing up a exactly
everyone else's plans like yeah the guy
playing Monopoly the flips table
the most power yeah for sure the game's
over yeah or your aunt Joyce who does
that but I know your aunt Joyce I knew
you're a choice number two please
number two's Daenerys Targaryen she's
got some power that one again she's got
the armies she's got people that are
swearing fealty to her people are
listening to her she's a huge threat
Danny dude they're like no-brainer like
she showed up to Westeros and she pretty
much owned it man she took out those
tallies like to make a make a point
right think about what a legend Aegon is
and it's like yeah Danny's gonna the
same story about her she came in and
she's a legend she's a weapon a Burnout
especially if she also takes down the
night king good face so then if she's
number two yeah number one man the most
powerful person in the Game of Thrones
this season does not even care about the
game of Thrones it's the night king oh
this was such I was just saying this is
such a good season for him go back and
look at everything the night king did
this season and it all goes well for him
it's almost like when when you're
playing like the ideas I've been and you
like roll20 and it's like I didn't even
expect it to go that well for me yeah a
little bit check it out yeah he's got
great aim as well at 10:00 that's kinda
what I mean like everything that he
attempts goes so well for him Jim Jim
okay so miraculously I have a nice spear
and there's like a dragon circling it's
definitely moving but I want to throw a
spear at it and kill it like nearly
instantly are you reckon that's what you
think it's gonna sound like yeah just
like a douchey Bros yeah Kappa theta
dead people yeah well I'm still yeah
he's a bro he's a waiter he's everything
I'm in love with him I think he's
amazing and I'm so impressed with the
fact that the show is like not letting
the heroes kind of like show weaknesses
in him yet because like he I think he's
gonna be the big threat obviously for
season eight combined
circe from the south yeah you know him
and for the north-south war on two
fronts but I be if he is what he's been
plus to add a motivation to him oh man
that's what I'm really hoping for I'm
kind of upset if they don't do yeah I'm
really excited about the possibility
something out there and we are going
into prediction submit is the best way
to get by season eight predictions
there's so much that's happening and
what could happen but this flash into my
head so I'm gonna completely go off
script and just drop this one says he's
pregnant has a boy night King turns it
in front of her so he just like takes
like a quick ride down to King's Landing
and he's like wearing like like tan
makeup beautiful baby can I hold it and
then he does AB sit if he's got really
no God he could be one of the faceless
men that we never knew about and the old
gods and the new gods he could be all of
it he could be a god this isn't crazy
enough give me one more thing
Krakens gonna eat a dragon is that
honestly is that Kraken that gray
elephant you're talking about
there are gonna there's gonna be a
Kraken picking up an elephant when he
goes and picks up the golden company
elephants are gonna be a fun addition
this whole thing yeah I mean I kind of
went through through definitely what I
was saying with the knight Kings gonna
be like the threat from the north I do
think that they will add a motivation to
him I mean we're gonna find out like why
come back yeah I would hope so something
related to them where he may be that
it's a personal reason with them kind of
he's like he wants to avenge what they
did to him or something
also in season eight yeah well
definitely figure out what happens with
Circe's pregnancy I don't think gonna
end well because of the valonqar
valonqar prophecy well the megatron's
prophecy yeah
and oh I think that it's it's gonna be a
little frustrating because I've said it
before I don't love when people on the
same side fight I think there's gonna be
huge strife between John and Danny when
they find out got it okay I don't want
there to be but I think there will be I
think brands gonna serve an amazing
purpose
I think bran and Tommen are going to get
it on weather
in a boat or not not sure kind of
sounded like she said brand and torment
Oh Bree Bree in an amazing purpose and I
also think we are going to see the team
up again of the Hound Anaya that'd be
great I think that reunion is is
definitely an impressive one especially
now he knows that she's like a great
fighter Mary yeah that's good Maya has
to get the rest of her list going and
she's got little fingers face so of
course she's gonna be infiltrating this
south with Littlefinger depends on it if
the word spreads about little fingers
death if it doesn't yeah
chatty people who does the veil answer
to though well a little Robin air we
will need to be eight feet tall but
still awkward as hell and I don't want
to bring up well we hear everyone's like
Oh Neffe that's so gross at one stage
Sansa was set to marry Robin Arryn her
cousin mm-hmm they're cousins yeah there
you go yeah and he's a sickly cousin so
it's an even worse combination that's a
pretty I think we're doing an impression
of his face oh good oh then I'm sorry
that I thought you were just you were
just making anyway my last thing I I
mean I said earlier Winterfell it's all
gonna come down to Winterfell sure we're
not gonna say anymore dawn we're not
gonna know anymore about marine we just
don't care anymore huh no you could even
see on the map like it's gone there's no
one there anymore are you naharis is he
gonna come back that'd be cool but man
we'll see he's running marine maybe he's
happy he's probably living quite the
life actually guys watch to the end of
this video to see the artwork that you
guys submitted for what those seven
gentlemen were up to north of the wall
while they were waiting for Danny to
show up and save all of their asses you
guys did some amazing stuff I'm so proud
of you yeah thank you tag me in those
two so I get to see them as well and
thanks so much for watching all season
long and letting us you know do
something new weird yeah he's still
putting out with my puns I don't know if
everyone did but I did I enjoyed them I
did they're funny also make sure you
subscribe to this channel for all sorts
of the Game of Thrones content yes there
is going to be even more content even
after this
done and following new rock stars on
Twitter to keep up with everything else
this channel has going on including ooh
a brand new show that is starting up
very soon if I do you can follow me at
Maude Garrett and if you are on YouTube
right now it's probably a jump over to
geek balm and give that a sub because I
think I'm gonna get one of those it's
silver the silver button oh cool oh you
better hit the 100k yeah I know you
didn't really get 100k away my the first
like 50k were the hardest and I was like
this honestly like the most proud of
that
I'm very impressed by what you've done
there it's a great Channel yes we do
have a dandy s style show you can see
this face yeah there's another episode
with me soon I think I'm full Melina you
guys have talked to me on Twitter
already but keep doing it that fimo I
love it I'll see you next time thanks
guys
bye bye